Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my flash versus savitar
speed force explainer video also has some
updates about what's going on during the break
at the end of this there is a new round of
the flash ring giveaway that starting now.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video I'm also
naming this week's winner at the end of this
video be sure to click that bell to enable
alerts so that you don't miss anything during
the break, but savitar, so we've already learned
a lot about him on the TV show but there's
a couple key differences from the comics the
give little insight as to why he's trapped
in the speed force, even though he calls himself
a speed God, but that's actually a really
important point he chose the name's savitar
for himself, the Hindu god of motion that
that doesn't mean that he's actually a God.
So as he says you only need people to believe
you're a God to become a God your smart about
before God you believe you are knowingly so
that doesn't mean that he has like this crazy
power that Barry does not have, but when you
look at the comics especially savitar storyline
there are many different ways that you can
become a speedster, you can gain your power
through magic like through enchantment like
Max Mercury back in the 1830s this dying Indian
shaman gave him his speed.
So you can also get your power from the speed
formula like the rival of the comics the reverse
flash of the Jay Garrick era the Edward Clariss
reverse flash they change that for the TV
show in the comics like way back in the Golden
age of the flash during the Jay Garrick era
he gave himself velocity nine that's how he
got his speed and then like Jesse quick like
Johnny quick you can use the speed formula
to give yourself speed, but as, of savitar's
debut in the comics.
They had only started to learn about the speed
force, so the people that wrote the flash
comic had a lot of different ways of explaining
how the flash got his powers, but the speed
force is a concept wasn't created until Mark
Wade's run.
So before that the flash is ran really fast,
but after Mark Wade created the idea of the
speed force, especially leading into the savitar
arc it change the nature of the flash is powers
but he still have a lot of different types
of speedsters getting there speed from different
sources.
So, what the TV show is done is it simplified
this a little bit and all of the good speedsters
that you've seen so far get their power from
the speed force but they all have different
levels of ability like Wally West is progressing
through his training much faster than Barry
did.
So just remember the idea that not all speedsters
are created equal and that includes savitar,
so in the comics savitar got his powers when
he was struck by lightning in an aircraft
he was a Cold War era pilot we never learned
his name when he woke up amidst the wreckage
of his plane he found that he had superspeed.
So he killed a bunch of people took the name's
savitar and then eventually ran afoul of Max
Mercury.
But as Max Mercury was trying to fight him.
He got a taste of the speed force and just
went completely drunk on it.
He started worshiping the speed force as a
God in wanted to commune with it more and
more, but because he didn't get his powers
from the speed force he wasn't connected to
it in the way that Wally West was.
So all he could do was steal speed from other
people that would make him faster, more powerful,
but there was an absolute limit.
So what happens is is you have all the speedsters
to get their powers from places that are not
the speed force like Jesse quick the formula
speedsters velocity nine speedsters anybody
else like Max Mercury the got it from the
Indian shaman savitar is able to steal all
of their speed.
So Wally West is left to take down savitar
by himself but one of the key cornerstones
of the Wally West character is that he had
always lived in grief of how Barry Allen had
died and had erected mental blocks for himself
that prevented him from reaching his full
potential as a speedster's over the course
of several adventures he's able to overcome
this fully tap into the speed force in runs
savitar right into it, trapping him he becomes
pure energy savitar is trapped in the speed
force prison, but the reason that he can't
get out is because the nature of his powers
do not connect him with the speed force in
the way that Wally is so he sort of trapped
in this endless void of time and energy.
The way they say on the TV show.
So what we know about TV savitar he got his
powers from the philosopher's stone not directly
from the speed force in the way that Barry
or Wally got their powers.
So the thing about Barry is that the speed
force as he spoke to that speed force wormhole
aliens in season two they chose him he is
like the universes champion the way they played
it was a little confusing this a little bit
different than the comics because in the comics
the speed force is just an energy source in
what you do with energy you use it to power
things there's no intelligence behind it.
But the TV show has turned it into more of
a Star Trek deep space nine thing where you
have beings that existed in this continuum
and have a will they exerted upon the universe.
They have a divine purpose and Barry is an
instrument of that.
But as we've learned from season two people
like zoom can gain the speed force.
They can get powers even though these beings
did not choose him is a champion.
So evil people can gain speed different ways
through circumstance and that sounds like
the way savitar got his powers he found the
philosopher's stone that gave him his powers
he became superfast he can siphon speed from
other people, but he's not connected to the
speed force in the way that Barry is so that's
why he can be so powerful but still be trapped
inside the speed force, so during the midseason
finale Jay Garrick made a really offhanded
remark, and it was almost lost like a second
time I watched it I heard a little bit more
clearly some to play this clip is that she
really important idea that is kind of throughout
their touchstone is loaded with gravimetric
for something to think you can run fast enough
to enter speed force and carry that same time
he can with my health be run as fast as we
can you trail behind me siphon with some of
my speed combined it with their own when you
have a nostril that Think Different speed
force, so here's the important thing they
kind of done this before on the flash this
is the first time that two people have run
together to enable one to run even faster
than he normally would be able to run they've
done it with the reverse flash, but here Jay
Garrick is actually saying it out loud in
a way that they haven't done before you can
siphon my speed and that will enable you to
throw the philosopher's stone into the speed
force, so on the TV show were already borrowing
giving taking speed between speedsters in
a way that's different from season to where
Harrison wells had to siphon it off using
that special device like it was really hard
for zoom to take Barry speed, but here he's
taking Jay Garrick speed and a really easy
offhanded way like it's no big deal.
So that's actually a huge concept and what
it sounds like is happening here is that Barry
is going to get the arc from the comics where
Wally had to overcome his mental block, so
a lot of you asked how fast is Barry has he
reached his full potential.
I will say he is definitely not as fast as
he will ever get he will get even faster by
the end of the season.
He'll have to in order to defeat's savitar
just like they deepen the mythology of the
flash each new season with each new villain
will deepen the mythology by allowing Barry
to more fully tap into the speed force will
become so fast that he can trap savitar in
the speed force again just like they did in
the comics so you just have to remember that
the flash TV show blends a lot of Wally West
era.
A lot of Golden age era and.
A lot of modern era flash, so that's why I
think that Barry is getting some Wally West
era, comic book story at least as it applies
to the nature of the speed force, so hopefully
that explains why savitar is supposedly a
God of speed yet he is trapped inside the
speed force.
When Barry went there himself.
I mean, he had that died to do it but I think
in the future he'll just become so fast that
he can go into the speed force and come back
out at will.
But if you guys want I will do a full flash
versus savitar comic book storyline bonus
video I might have to break it up into a couple
because it's really big story but that'll
happen during the break, I'm doing a bunch
of epic comic book battle videos like the
flash versus Iris West is like a really cool
twist from the comics so the be all kinds
a bonus videos like that but what can happen
later tonight is the Spider-Man trailer is
going to be dropping.
I'm totally gonna do a video for it.
But they just revealed that there's a second
trailer with slightly different footage so
I'll be doing to Spider-Man trailer videos,
but the first one will post later tonight
than the next one will dispose Friday morning.
So instead of just one Spider-Man trailer
you get to is gonna be awesome.
There is the midseason finale of legends of
tomorrow Capt. cold.
Does that make sure you watch that episode
because of that Spider-Man stuff my video
for that will post till Friday morning.
So no worries.
I will do legends of tomorrow.
I will do agents of shield, but because there's
so much stuff happening.
I'll just update the schedule as I post new
videos.
So it's gonna be a lot of fun.
Let me know what kind of flash bonus videos
you want me to do during the break the flash
episode 10 is coming back January 24.
So, I know that sounds like a long time but
a section out that long, but the flash ring
giveaway will still be happening every week
so I'll say congratulations to this week's
winner Mr. Scully please private message me
on the back and my channel so I can get your
contact details and I did start a new round
of the beginning of this, so I'll announce
the winner when I post that legends of tomorrow
video what you guys wait for that to post
you can click here for the Spider-Man teaser
trailer and you can click here for my flash
episode nine video think you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight!